and lo everyone Perry here with another
Sundance 2019 interview I am sitting
with the team responsible for the
souvenir and we have the opportunity to
talk to them thanks to the Kia Telluride
so huge thanks to our great sponsor for
making this happen I have to do this
just to jump right in because a lot of
our viewers do not know what the
souvenir is just yet so would either of
you mind giving a brief synopsis it's a
portrait of a young woman who wants to
be a filmmaker who gets involved with a
very charismatic man and he is very
supportive of her ambitions to be a
director but also destroys her
confidence in some ways and I know that
this is semi autobiographical for you so
I was wondering what inspired you to
tell your story this particular way well
it took me many years actually to feel
ready to tell the story I think probably
30 years ago I started thinking about
making a film on the subject and then it
just takes a long time to develop these
things I'd write ideas and notebooks and
then it just felt like the right time to
do it out of curiosity when you first
jumped into it compared to what I saw
last night are there any drastic changes
that happens a lot of changes happen a
lot of changes is changing all the time
in fact when we're making it is there
any tailoring these characters to the
fine folks that you cast in this film
because I'll be honest like I can't
picture your role any other way with any
other person in it well I'm yeah I met
Tom early on in the casting process and
I didn't look any further and what was
it like for you to know that she saw you
as a perfect fit for that role which is
I probably will not be able to shake for
a while and we were just talking
actually about how I see a lot of
midnight movies but it's different to
see someone who is an outright you know
easy to label villain versus someone
that's destructive to another person but
in a very natural almost subtle kind of
way yeah
I've always been fascinated by how the
most insecure people a lot of effort and
time goes into cultivating a kind of
note of certainty in their voice so that
to other people they appear to have the
whole picture and that can really draw
people in and Anthony I think seems like
one of those people when you first meet
him he seems to have the whole picture
he seems to have certainty he's almost a
kind of fundamentalist about art but
it's hiding this black hole inside him
and and one of Joanna's huge strengths
as a creator is her is her mobility and
so you really feel that you're allowed
to to make something around and that you
know that you're a kind of co-creator in
it and so yeah and just an answer to
that question yet you really felt you
could and there was a constant not only
a dialogue but I felt sort of beyond
dialogue as a sense of complicity even
about the kind of where I was sitting in
relation to the you know cuz I I'm one
of the first things we did I I sort of
cameras over there I kind of angled my
background because that just kind of
felt right and then I was going is that
fear am i doing that cuz I'm just scared
and it's like the second day and and I
think you came over and you said I quite
like it it's just you're this shape
emanating smoke and and so I I don't
know that it was a real complicity
between us all and David the DOP it just
it just felt like we all knew what story
we were telling even though it was
developing and changing with that point
in mind it makes me wonder what you like
to go to set with in hand in terms of
prep storyboarding anything like that or
do you like to stay more fluid because
some of these shots are just so specific
where you know a shot of the two of you
talking that just lets them sit and
breathe in a scene yes yeah well I
really fluid is the word I don't like
coming to search with anything in a way
I mean of course I'm thinking
working all the time as we're shooting
were shooting in story order which
really helps that fluidity but I really
I don't want anything in my hands I
don't 100 page script to carry around
because I want to observe and and and
and use my instinct and and I've got all
the material in front of me so no prep
material at hand but do you go with like
a coffee or something like that
coffee always considering that what was
the extent of this shoot how much time
do you have to do something like this
because there's some primary locations
but it does feel like you guys are kind
of all over the place and that the scale
and scope of this it feels big to me
well it's interesting because there was
not there was no scope in the sense that
we were in one place we were in an
aircraft hangar which was the setting of
the film school but the apartment is
built inside and then some of the
locations outside all in one building I
mean there's actually we were in a tiny
little area which was bliss because it
means there's more time to work there's
more time to play does that make it a
challenge from a visual perspective
feeling like you're stuck in one place
on one stand stage or even with the
apartment and things like establishing
the geography of the apartment - I find
it really exciting actually the more the
more limits in a way the more creative
you can be is there any specific example
of a situation where you were limited in
some respect and something beautiful
came out of it that everybody can keep
an eye out for I think I it's time it's
so liberating to work with the director
who is not obsessed with close-ups Oh
seeing your eyes or you know there's
this kind of idea that the eyes carry
the emotion and of course we all know
what what people mean by that but but
there's so many other things to read
especially in a two-shot or a wide and I
think there was once or twice when you
were almost tempted to come in close and
we kind of ran out of time and
I'm sure you would have ended up using
the too short or the weight anyway
because it just it just it's it's it
it's such a more it's just such a
different way of watching a film when
when you just hold back from that and
you're seeing knees and shoulders and
instead of just you know this all the
time but body language is so important
and the choreography of a shot and and
yeah when you admit exactly when you
stand back you can see the bodies moving
within space and that's so interesting
and I find yes if I'm suddenly you know
at the end of the day and we got half an
hour left for a scene often that scene
you get the magic in it and yeah I can
definitely see that happening also the
this shots where you're sitting opposite
one another that's when the body
language is kind of vital to me rather
than the traditional cutting back and
forth but I obviously have to talk a
little bit about honor here because oh
my oh my for a first lead role in a
feature film this is clearly not easy
whatsoever so one what made you
confident in her ability to take this on
and then to what kind of burning
questions did she have for you before
you started shooting well I I mean I
there was just a moment when I met her
quite late in the casting process
it's almost wondering if I was gonna
find the right person and she was
talking about her experience it was just
spontaneous it was it was just a
conversation it wasn't the casting
session or anything but she was talking
about her experience as a 19 year old
she was 19 when we shot the film and
there was something in what she said
that made me think that's Julie and then
from that moment I have that little
moment of realization and then I don't
well I didn't waver I mean I didn't
doubt anything I felt like I had her and
then we go on that journey and I enjoyed
I enjoy seeing what's going to unfold so
we don't have any audition process and
she very bravely unlike with Tom didn't
see a single thing written down so she
didn't have so many of the burning
questions because she was willing she
said I'm gonna come on the journey with
with you and so you know we took each
other's hand and day by day went through
the story and she just
covered it as it was happening to follow
up on something he just brought up what
was the the specific thing she said to
you that really just made you made her
and the role of Julie click in your mind
it's a little it's a little bit personal
to be honest but it was just something
about it it was something that connected
with my own experience of being that age
and it so there was a little yeah kind
of twinship moment where I just thought
yes
and there's another personal level to
that relationship too because they
believe you're friendly with Tilda to
her mother but was also because you just
mentioned that she came up rather late
in the casting process honor was Tilda
I'm bored from the start and then just
later in the game said like why don't
you consider on her well she I can't
remember exactly at the exact point that
Tilda was involved but it wasn't right
at the beginning but it was at a certain
point when I was still finding Julie and
I thought okay I better get you know but
it cost across the film and and there
was no question of honor in the picture
at that point I mean honor has never
considered acting as a career you know
she was 19 just shortly out of school
you know she's I need to go to
university so you know it was something
that really happened when I was visiting
Tilda to talk about the role of a mother
and an honor and I crossed over we were
on a platform she was coming up to
Scotland and I was going back down to
London so we just had this moment on
that on the railway platform this
conversation and that that's when that
moment occurred and then of course it
was up to one or two decide if it was
something she wanted to do yeah that is
incredible I know she's not here right
now has she seen the film and and how
does she feel about seeing herself on
the big screen in her first feature film
well not her first but at least first in
the leading role I remember she was in I
am loved I think yes yes yes no it's her
first big big role and she has seen the
film I think she's now seen it three
times because I wanted her to see it on
her own to start off with to to
experience it because it's a big deal
when you see yourself I don't know what
it feels like actually but I can imagine
it's a big deal sitting yourself on the
screen for the first time
and and then Tom also saw it ahead of
Sundance because I didn't want either of
them to see the film for the first time
here that's yeah can you identify that
with that at all do you like watching
yours I mean maybe not like watching
yourself on screen but do you like to
watch your films especially before
premieres ticket there's so many other
thoughts kick in while you're watching
yourself so it's quite hard to just sit
back and yeah but I think you know I as
testament to the film when you are able
to do that and I really certainly the
first time I saw it was just completely
kind of absorbed in it and obviously the
second time there's an audience so it's
a little different and you both went
into the screening last night with it
being public knowledge that you're
shooting the sequel this summer so just
curious
were you kind of waiting nervously for
the reaction out of this part knowing
that you're already teed up to go make
another movie I didn't think of it
exactly in that way but I haven't looked
at anything written about the film from
last night because I don't want to find
I'm reading something a reaction to the
first one that will make me
self-conscious about anything I do in
the second one because I think that the
sort of name of the game really is is is
freedom taking risks I don't consider
them really risk but I just want to be
able to play and not think about what
somebody said about the film in the back
of my head without giving too much away
just scrolling through Twitter I'll just
like give you a thumbs up I saw a lot of
positivity in there are you able to
tease anything about plans for the
sequel and how you're gonna evolve the
characters involved I'm gonna just say
very very little because what also
because I'm still working it out to be
honest and and I don't want to I don't
want to say something that's going to
happen and then I decide it won't happen
because the process changes honestly day
by day so much I mean it always ends up
coming back round kind of what I
intended in the beginning but it just
goes on this journey but it yeah I mean
it it's we're going to shoot in June
which is very exciting unfortunately not
with Tom but it's going to be a
continuation of
of the journey of a portrait of a
filmmaker I am very very eager to see
that a huge congratulations on this
movie guy is the souvenir keep an eye
out for it from a 24 thank you so much
for being here today thank you for Kia
Telluride because they make all this
happen and we are super grateful for it
like and share this video we will see
you soon with more Sundance coverage
you